one of the famous stories about this
movie is involves the ending and the
fact that there was debate on the set of
whether the ending was too sentimental
whether it were me that was me I said
look I just I went to tailor like we
were going to shoot this thing the next
day I said tailor come on we're never
going to use this is it the dopiest
ending we did this really tough movie
and you know come on and he said I know
but yeah it's in the squad we just
shooted we're gonna be here
why don't we we'll just shoot it and did
you think it would be in the movie we
after we shot it I still didn't think it
would work and ironically the when we
the early cuts of the film had different
music on it and it didn't work for me it
didn't work and and then it was this
music but a different tempo and it
didn't work and I came in to see one cut
that had this tempo and I got chills in
the back of my neck seeing it because
everything was right all of a sudden
there was something about the tempo of
the music brought everything together
the question is is he stunned at how big
that movie became I'm stunned I'm
sitting here right now
that I have a career that's actually
made some things that touch people you
know I came from a very simple place so
the fact that my life has had this arc
to it amazes me but that movie look you
can't you can't make that movie a movie
like that has to happen and it's look
you guys are not fools you know there's
400 people working on a movie and if any
one of them screws up the movie doesn't
work and for whatever reason that all
came together the the the magic potion
mix of that story with Garry Marshall
and Julia and me and everyone else and
it just came together it had the right
tone and had a quality we got along all
got along in a certain way
it just found its place but probably of
all the movies I've made that's the one
that wherever I am in the world in
whatever culture I'm in I believe me any
culture whether it's deep Asia its
Borneo its Europe in South America it's
Antarctica it's wherever it is that
movie has spoken to people and again why
I don't know and again you can't there's
no magic formula you can follow to make
that happen it's it's a piece of pure
magic well that was the most fun for
sure Chicago was without a doubt the
most fun I ever had make a movie without
a doubt Wow and it was it was just at
the right time - it was like I was my
son was just born and we were getting
along so great and and it was recalling
the time my early career when I started
acting in New York I was doing musicals
and and it was just and Rob Marshall was
such a skilled and generous director I
created an atmosphere that was so loving
and open and creative and fun just froze
just pure fun beginning to end